Trascrizione: Vanessa G
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
(Applausi)
Grazie mille.
Fallire è la cosa più bella
che potrebbe capitarci,
se solo riuscissimo
a normalizzarlo e ad accettarlo.
Io vedo i fallimenti
un po’ come una scena del crimine,
un cadavere per terra,
perché, mentre i successi e le vittorie
vengono esaltati e dimenticati
immediatamente, i fallimenti no.
I fallimenti vengono
analizzati al microscopio,
archiviati e tirati fuori
in caso di necessità.
Per alzata di mano, quanti di voi
possono sinceramente ammettere
di aver fallito almeno
una volta nella vita?
Dio, facciamo schifo veramente,
è una roba imbarazzante.
Però, quanti di quelli
che hanno alzato la mano, tutti,
possono dire di aver
accettato un fallimento?
Pochi, molto pochi.
La paura di fallire è talmente forte
che ne è addirittura
spuntata fuori una sindrome.
In psicologia, la sindrome del fallito
è quella costante sensazione
di non aver avuto successo in nulla
e di non avere la possibilità
di cambiare la situazione,
facendo credere a chi ne soffre
che tutto ciò che fa
o che dice sia sbagliato.
Può essere frutto di motivi immaginari,
reali, ma il risultato sarà sempre
un senso di insoddisfazione,
di sé stesso, della propria vita,
che spesso porta a sprofondare
nella frustrazione e nella rinuncia.
Per questo motivo, le persone che hanno
paura di fallire tendono ad evitare
i rischi e a non andare mai oltre
la propria comfort zone,
cercando di vivere meglio,
cercando di vivere uno stile di vita
molto, molto, molto tranquillo
e molto normale, senza correre rischi.
Io ho fallito molto nella mia vita,
ma non soffro della sindrome del fallito,
perché se sono qui a parlare ad un TEDx
vuol dire che qualche successo l’ho avuto.
Ed infatti soffro della sindrome
dell’impostore, che è quella sindrome
che ti fa pensare di non meritare
il successo che hai.
E la sindrome del fallito
e la sindrome dell’impostore
sono in mezzo a questo sandwich
del cervello chiamato “pipponi mentali”.
(Risate)
Quindi, riassumendo, la pressione
psicologica dovuta a un fallimento
porta le persone
non solo a non provarci più
ma a non correre mai nessun rischio.
Qual è il posto, secondo voi,
dove sperimentiamo
per la prima volta il fallimento?
Sicuramente, come molti di voi, come me,
sarà a scuola o all’università.
Pensiamo a non aver superato
un’interrogazione, a non aver superato
un esame o al fallimento
per eccellenza: la bocciatura.
La bocciatura non è solo
il fallimento di un obiettivo,
il fallimento dell’anno,
non aver superato l’anno,
ma parte da quello.
È una spirale che non ha fine,
che chi non è stato bocciato
non ne ha idea.
Fallisci l’obiettivo,
deludi i tuoi genitori,
che sono qui in quarta fila,
ripeti l’anno in una classe di alunni
che non hanno la tua età,
che sono più piccoli di te
e che tu non conosci,
ti senti inadeguato e vieni costantemente
giudicato e indicato come quello bocciato.
Ne so qualcosa perché ci sono passato,
ma non sono mai arrivato a questo punto:
bocciato all’esame, si presenta a scuola
e uccide l’insegnante a colpi di machete.
È un fatto tragico e non sono
assolutamente d’accordo con i modi,
ma lo capisco molto bene, anche perché
la bocciatura è il vero primo fallimento
che ti porti dietro per sempre.
Ma cosa succede quando riesci non solo
a superarlo ma anche ad accettarlo,
un fallimento?
Gary Dahl è un pubblicitario a cui,
nel 1975, viene in mente un’idea folle.
Nonostante nessuna banca voglia
finanziargliela, dandola per fallita
in partenza, lui decide di ipotecare
una seconda volta la sua casa
e, con i soldi fatti, comprare piccoli
spazi pubblicitari in riviste e giornali
per vendere il suo prodotto.
La sua idea è quella di vendere
come animale domestico
una pietra.
Pet rock, la “pietra domestica”.
Non ridere!
Almeno, questa pietra
non sporca, non fa rumori,
e a nessuno frega niente
se l’abbandoni in autostrada, nessuno.
(Risate)
L’idea però va a puttane, esattamente
come tutte le banche avevano predetto.
Ma Dahl non si dà per vinto, non si lascia
schiacciare da questo fallimento.
Con i suoi ultimi 200 dollari,
compra un piccolissimo spazio
pubblicitario nel mese di novembre,
poco prima di Natale,
e riesce a vendere 1,5 milioni di pietre
che la gente ha regalato a Natale
come animale domestico.
Babbo Natale odia quei bambini
che hanno ricevuto questa pietra.
Lui aveva un guadagno
di 2 dollari per pietra
e, in poco più di due mesi,
ha guadagnato 3 milioni di dollari
vendendo pietre.
Dahl è l’esempio di una persona
che ha accettato l’idea di fallire
senza smettere di credere in quello
che sapeva avrebbe funzionato.
Questo vuol dire che la paura ci pone
dei limiti enormi, al punto di offuscare
la mente, tanto da farci credere
che idee che potrebbero funzionare,
invece, non funzionerebbero mai.
Ma ci sono altri esempi di persone
che hanno avuto un grande successo
partendo da un fallimento.
Negli anni ’70,
un uomo vede un ciclone portare via
tutta la polvere di legno da una segheria,
lasciandola completamente pulita.
Lui guarda questo evento
e dice: “Sai che devo fare?
Voglio miniaturizzare quello che ho visto
e venderlo nelle case di tutti”.
Le persone intorno a lui hanno detto:
“Tu sei nato scemo, tu sei scemo”.
Mi stavano attaccando.
Ci vogliono, però, 5 anni e 5000 diverse
versioni di piccoli fallimenti
per fare questa aspirapolvere.
E, quando finalmente lui ha
un bel aspirapolvere da poter vendere,
nessuno glielo vuole distribuire.
Con qualche soldo, riesce ad aprire
un mercato, prima, in Giappone,
poi, con i soldi che fa in Giappone,
che vanno benissimo, in Inghilterra
e poi, dall’Inghilterra,
arriva a tutto il mondo.
Quell’uomo è...
Manca una foto.
È James Dyson, il creatore della Dyson.
Non è lui James Dyson, assolutamente.
(Risate)
Lui, invece...
(Applausi)
Un applauso a Dyson,
si è perso nelle foto.
Quanto a lui, invece,
per fare un altro esempio,
nel 1959, un gruppo del Partito
del Risorgimento Arabo Socialista
decide di preparare un attentato
al primo ministro iracheno di allora,
al-Karīm Qāsim.
Questo gruppo non era proprio
esperto in attentati,
era uno dei loro primi attentati.
Quindi, decidono di farlo
in una delle strade
più trafficate di Baghdad.
Qasim sarebbe passato in mezzo con l’auto
e loro si sarebbero divisi
metà da una parte e metà
dall’altra parte della strada.
Dimenticandosi una minuzia,
una quisquiglia, cioè che, se tu ti metti
metà da una parte, metà
dall’altra, quando spari...
(Risate)
Qasim riesce a scappare,
loro si sparano tra di loro, e non solo:
il capo ideatore, il genio che ha creato
questo attentato è nientepopodimeno che...
(Risate)
Saddam Hussein.
Se...
(Applausi)
Avete appena applaudito a Saddam Hussein.
Fate voi, fate voi.
Io non vi ho detto niente.
Tanto registrano qua, son cazzi vostri.
Anche perché non tutti possono essere
imprenditori di successo,
qualcuno si deve sacrificare
e diventare un dittatore.
Ma tornando alla scienza, il fallimento
non ha solo conseguenze psicologiche,
come abbiamo visto, ma anche fisiche.
Infatti, è causa di ansia e stress,
che portano il corpo
a rilasciare cortisolo.
Ah, la foto è giusta.
Quando sperimentiamo una vittoria,
il nostro corpo rilascia endorfine
che ci stimolano a impegnarci
e ad andare avanti.
Il cortisolo, invece, è l’esatto opposto.
È definito come l’ormone dello stress
e alimenta una risposta di fuga davanti
a una situazione critica,
quindi ci fa peggiorare una situazione
già stressante di suo.
Viene prodotto su impulso del sistema
nervoso,
che aumenta
l’accumulo di grassi nel sangue
e l’aumento di glicemia
nei momenti in cui
all’organismo serve energia.
Alti livelli di cortisolo
per lunghi periodi di tempo
possono anche danneggiare la parte
del cervello associata all’apprendimento,
alla memoria e al controllo dello stress
e possono portare a depressione, ansia
e problemi di cuore.
Quindi, se tu sei una persona già affetta
da ansia sociale di tuo
e cammini per strada
e qualcuno ti chiede che ore sono,
ti si alza il cortisolo,
ti scoppia il cuore
muori lì sul marciapiede.
Pensa che brutto morire
perché qualcuno ti ha chiesto l’ora.
Pensa che fallimento.
Per mantenere stabili i livelli
di cortisolo, bisogna alleviare lo stress
e per farlo ci sono vari modi.
Per esempio, migliorando
il proprio stile di vita,
il metodo fisico,
migliorare il proprio fisico
e stile di vita,
fare esercizio fisico, adottare
tecniche di rilassamento come lo yoga
o la meditazione,
dormire il numero giusto di ore di notte,
non come stiamo facendo
noi in questo momento,
e bilanciare
il rapporto proteine/carboidrati,
cioè mangiare un po’ meglio.
Oppure migliorare
il proprio stato mentale.
Quindi, coltivando delle passioni,
avere degli hobby e ridere,
molto ridere.
Ovviamente, in certe situazioni,
ridere diventa un po’ complicato.
Ma non vi preoccupate
perché c’è una soluzione anche a quello.
Uno studio ha rivelato
che il cervello e il nostro corpo
non riescono a capire esattamente
la differenza tra la risata vera
e la risata finta.
Quindi,
quando voi siete a Natale, con quello zio
che vi racconta quella barzelletta
un po’ omofoba e voi ridete
per evitare i problemi,
“Ah ah ah, zio, mannaggia la miseria!”,
il corpo rilascia comunque endorfine
e abbassa i livelli di cortisolo,
perché il nostro cervello,
ogni tanto, è un deficiente.
Questo vuol dire che, se noi riuscissimo
ad accettare i fallimenti
e a normalizzarli nella società,
il peso psicologico e il dolore fisico
sparirebbero e riusciremmo a riderne,
creando endorfine invece che cortisolo.
Però, ora come ora, per il periodo storico
e per i problemi personali, non è così.
Quindi, vi lascio con una cosa
che potrebbe aiutarvi
nel caso vi sentiste
sopraffatti da un fallimento.
C’è Pierino
(Risate)
che va dal papà e gli chiede: “Papà, se io
prendo 10 a scuola, tu mi dai 10 euro?”
“Certo, Pierino.”
“Perfetto. E allora dammi 3 euro
perché ho preso 3 in matematica”.
(Risate)
Avete riso ad una barzelletta
su Pierino, nel 2022.
Per tutti quelli che non hanno riso,
non vi preoccupate,
potete sempre fare finta.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)
Grazie.